اهلا بكم اتحدث اليوم الى رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني السابق عمران خان سنناقش معه
ازمته الشخصيه وازمه حزبه وازمه بلاده
عامه وسنرى ما يعرضه مقابل اقناع الجيش
للحكومه حسب رايه بالجلوس لحل تلك الازمات
وما الذي يمكن ان يقنع المؤسسه العسكريه
القويه بذلك في ظل عزلته الخارجيه
والداخليه في مقره بحديقه الزمن احييكم
اينما كنتم من العربيه انا منتهى الرمحي
وهذا البعد الاخر
[موسيقى]
اسمحوا لي ان ارحب بالسيد عمران خان رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني الاسبق اهلا بك معنا
سيد عمران
معكم
دعني ابدا معك بالسؤال الذي يدور في ذهن
الكثيرين هل مازلت حتى هذه اللحظه حريصا
على الحوار مع الجيش
انا رجل سياسي
وسياسيون دائما يؤمنون بحليم مشاكلهم عبر
الحوار
ومنذ ان
تم ازاحه حكومه عبر المؤامره انا دائما
مستعد لاعطي الحوار
وفيصل نجم وكانت لدينا
الوقت وحتى مع رئيس جيش عرضت عليه الحماره
اخرى والحوار لكن يجب ان كنا من جانبين
والى الان لم احصل على استجابه من قائد
الجيش طب لماذا الحوار مع الجيش مع
المؤسسه العسكريه وليس مع المدنيه ليس مع
الحكومه او اي تيار سياسي اخر على الساحه
الباكستانيه
كما تعرفين منتهى فان كل الاحزاب السياسيه
من دون المؤسسه العسكريه فهم لا يمثلون
شيئا
عندما تحدثنا عن الانتخابات
كانوا يتم ازاحتها من بين 37 انتخابات
حزبيه اكتسح 30 من على الرغم من الدعم
المؤسسه لهم ففي الحقيقه هم مجردين دمى
القوه الحقيقيه هي المؤسسه العسكريه طيب
هناك عقبات كثيره امام الوصول لاي امل في
الحوار الذي ترغب به البعض يرى بانه
الخشيه او خشيه الكثيرين من انتقامك في
حال عودتك يمكن ان تكون عقبه اخرى امام اي
امل في ذلك الحوار الذي ترغب به ماذا تقول
كما قلت انا اعمل في مجال السياسه وهذا
العمل ليس من اجلي بل من اجل بلادي انا
سياسيه الوحيد الذي منحه رب العالمين كل
شيء لم يكن لدي اي سبب يدفعني للانخراط في
مجال السياسي فقط انخرطت في هذا المجال
لانني اؤمن باننا حكم القانوني في
الباكستان حكم القانون يمنحنا لحريه
والازدهار
التقدم الدول على دول اخرى هي لان لديهم
العداله وحكم القانون
ففكرتي او هدفي هو ليس للساعه الانتقام من
اي احد
بل قبل 27 عاما عندما خرط في المجالس
السياسي حكم القانون في باكستان
والديمقراطيه الحقيقيه
الحقيقيه لا تاتي الا مع حكم القانون
وفي الحديث عن حكم القانون الالاف من
انصارك اصلا في السجن كمن سحب العشرات من
قاده حزبك ايضا
يمكن حظر هذا الحزب هل تمر بازمه كبيره
الان
هي ليست ازمه حزبي بل هي ازمه البلاد في
باكستان حاليا
لدينا حكم الغابه ولا يوجد حكم القانون
القضاء تم تقويضه بالكامل
والاعلام
ايضا اسكت تفاهه بالكامل اخرس بالكامل
ويسيطرون عليه بالكامل حزب السياسي وهو
اكبر حزب سياسي باكستان
واجهه اكبر عملياته قمع العشره الالاف
التي السجون وحتى القيادات العليا في
السجون اكثر من 150 قضيه رفعت ضدي
فما يحصل هو انه من خلال محاولتهم لتفكيك
حزبي
الديمقراطيه باكملها في باكستان تم
تفكيكها وهذا هو القلق الحقيقي اذا ما
دمرنا ديمقراطيه اي بلد فبالتالي ينمر
مستقبله هنا نتحدث عن مايسترو واحد لكل
هذه العمليات حسب رايك وهو الجيش او
المؤسسه العسكريه
او يعني قاعده جيش
قبل اسابيع كنا اجرينا معك حوار بعد تدخل
الجيش مباشره في عمليه الازاحه والسجن
وغيرها هل لك ان تضعني في صوره ما حدث هل
تغير اي شيء منذ ذلك التاريخ حتى الان
ما حصل
حوا انه اسلوب اعتقالي من المحكمه العليا
في اسلام اباد
وكان الجيش
او القوات الخاصه هم الذين جاؤوا لاعتقال
وعملوني ارهابي كانت هنالك رده فعل
اتجاهها ما حصل ولكن كلوا الامر كان مدبرا
واستخدموا واستغلوا رده الفعل لتفكيك
الحزب باكمله لانه خلال 48 ساعه كيتا
بامكانه
كيف يمكن تكون مثل عمليه القمع هذه ما لم
تكن مخططه او مدبره فكل شيء كان مدبرا حتى
اسلوب اعتقالي كان الشرطه ان تفعل ذلك او
حتى اعتقالي انا رجل بعمري سبعين عاما
الست بحاجه الى قوات خاصه لاعتقالي
فالمساله كلها كانت مدبره ردت الفعل
بالتاكيد كانت تكون هناك رده فعل لكنهم
استغلوها
للسعي الى تفكيك الحزب بالكامل
دقيقه في عام 1933 ادولت هتلر على نفس
الشيء
البرلمان الالماني في برلين حرق واستخدم
ذلك كذريعه
للسعي وراء خصومه وهم الشيوعيين ودمرهم
بالكامل طيب يعني اذا كانت المساله فيها
اي نوع من المقارنه مع العمليات القمعيه
التي حدثت على مستوى العالم وعالم مر
التاريخ لماذا لم نسمع اي مؤيدين لك في
الخارج يعني اي
ناقدين لتصرف الجيش او المؤسسه العسكريه
في باكستان عند عندما قامت بكل ما قامت به
[موسيقى]
من تجربتي في العلاقات الدوليه خاصه عندما
كنت في السلطه لثلاثه عوامل
المؤسسات الدوليه
[موسيقى]
يعني المؤسسه الجيش او المؤسسه العسكريه
الان لو عاد بك الزمن الى الوراء ما الذي
ستتجنبه من اخطاء لو كنت مقتنع ان هناك
اخطاء ارتكبتها
لم ارتكب ايه اخطاء
عملتم رئيسا للوزراء عملت مع قائد الجيش
هو الذي غدر به انا لم اخنه ابدا هو الذي
خانني وهو الذي قررت
ان يدعم رئيس الوزراء الحالي
وبالتالي فهو الذي يتامر لزاحه حكومتي انا
لم افعل شيئا حتى بعد ازاحتي عن السلطه
حاولت العمل مع الجيش
كل ما اريده في باكستان
لدينا انتخابات حره وعادله والتي ستؤدي
الى الاستقرار الان وحاسب فهمي لما ترغبه
المؤسسه العسكريه
فهي تريد الحكومه التاليه ان تكون من دوني
فهم لا يرغون بالانتخابات ما لم يضمنون
ازاحتي بالكامل عن المشهد او يتم تفكيك
وتدمير حزبي هذا ما يحصل انا ليس لدي اي
مشكله مع الجيش كل ما اريده في الباكس في
باكستان هناك حكم القانون وقائد الجيش
لديه مشكله معي فما يقومه يقوله زاهد امر
غير منطقي انا لم ارتكب اي خطا لماذا يريد
الجيش يعني ما الذي سيجعل الجيش يريد
التحدث معك الان وانت في وضع سياسي هش جدا
مع الاعتقالات التي حصلت مع احتماليه يعني
الانتهاء من حزبك تماما
اسمحي لي ان اوضح لك منتهى او يتحدثون عني
في موقف اضعف
الحزب
السياسي لا يكون الا في موقف ضعيف بعد ان
يخسر
داعميه لو كان ان اخي بنا قد تخلوا عني
فسيكون في موقف ضعيف اليوم حزبي حزب
الاصلاح هو اكبر حزب في تاريخ باكستان
وكلما قام بقمع حزبيه وكلما زادت القاعده
انظري الى اي
استطلاعات الراي في باكستان من بين 37
انتخابات الثانويه ب 30 منها فالجمهور الى
جانبي لذلك انا لست ضعيفا ولكن البلاد هي
التي تزداد ضعفا عندما نحاول ازاحه اكبر
حزب في البلاد ويستغلون
كافه الجهات الامنيه والمؤسسات التابعه
للدوله من اجل سحق حزبين فهم في الحقيقه
يدمرون البلاد وليس حزبين فالحزب سيبقى
قويا ما دعم لديه داعمين وهم اكبر جماعه
وقاعده في التاريخ البلاد ستعاني ان كانت
هذه العمليات ستستمر ولا يوجد حكم قانون
فقط حكم الغرب
والمؤسسات تزداد ضعفا عندما يدمرون مؤسسه
اي دوله فهم في الحقيقه يدمرون البلاد
نفسها طيب لنفترض الان انه الجيش قبل بان
يدخل في حوار معه قبل النقاش ماذا ستطرح
عليه ما هي مطالبك ما هي الخطه التي تقترح
من اجل ايجاد حل
اولا
اريد اتعرف على مشكله قائد الجيش
لانه قرر بشكل جليل بانني شخص لا يجب ان
يتسلم السلطه فاريد ان افهم السبب وراء
ذلك ما هي المشاكل
اهلا بكم معنا من جديد ونعود واياكم
لمتابعه حوارنا مع رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني السابق عمران خان ارحب بك من
جديد سيد خان
ودعني اسالك انت نفسك اعترفت بذلك وقلت
مرات عديده انا معزول اي خطه لكسر حاله
العزله نحن نعلم انك تؤكد دائما على
الجانب الاتصال اللي هو عن خلال اليوتيوب
والخطاب الخطاب التي تلقيها والتواصل مع
الاخرين هل تعتقد انه هذا يكفي
الحزب الذي لديه اكبر قاعده انتخابيه في
البلاد اذا ما حصل انتخابات سنفوز ان شاء
الله
اذا ما عقدت الانتخابات فانا على ثقه بذلك
مهما فعلوا مهما فعلت هذه المؤسسه
والاحزاب الحكوميه
ومهما كان عدد
كبار المسؤولين في الحزبنا القاعده في
الملايين لا يستطيعون جميعا في السجن فما
دامت هذه القاعده قويه ان شاء الله
بالانتخابات القادمه ولكن
الامر الاهم اذا ما تحدثت عن عزله نعم انا
معزول لان كل المسؤولين الكبار في حزبين
اما في حالاتي اختباء او في السجن
وليس لدي ادنى شكل بانهم عاجلا ام اجلا
سيسجنونني ايضا ساسافر لاسلام بعد يوم غد
الذي تسعه عشر قضيه وكفالات في 19 قضيه كل
ما عليهم فعله هو الغاء كفاله في قضيه
واحده وسيسجلني في السجن فانا مستعد ذهنيا
للسجن ولكن هذا لن يسمع لهم
بالدفع حزبي للخساره في انتخابات وسنفوز
فيها ان شاء الله طيب
يعني القضيه القانونيه قضيه معقده جدا
للحديث عنها الان في باكستان تتحدث عن 19
قضيه كلها خرجت بها بكفاله وانت تقول
بانها كلها قضايا ملفقه
كل هذه القضايا زائفه كلما اذهب الى
المحكمه
يسمح لي بالكفاله انه لا يوجد اي شيء قويه
في القضايا والان يقوم باعداد المحاكمه
العسكريه
فحكمه مدنيه التي تساعدني والان يعيدون
المحاكم العسكريه وتم اعدادها يرغبون
بسجنه
البعض يقول بانه يعني خاصه من الغرب انه
عمران خان وراء شكله الموجود الذي يظهر به
حاليا بالسلوان التقليدي الانيق يروج
لرؤيا للمجتمع شديده المحافظه حتى ان
بعضهم يربط ما يسمونه وجهك الجديد بزواجك
الاخير كيف ترى هذا التقييم
تعرفين
المشكله هي ان في الغرب لا يفهموننا ولا
يفهمون الاسلام
والغرب ينظر الى المجتمعات المسلمه وكاننا
منقسمون بين المتطرفين وبين الليبراليين
ولا يفهموننا ابدا لا يدركون بان كل
مجتمعات الانسانيه هي معاصره او معتدله
وهنالك بن علي يسار المحافظين وهنالك
تقدميين لا يفهمونني ينظرون اليه وكانني
رجل غربي معاصر وفي نفس الوقت لانني اعيش
حياتي وفقا لتعاليم الاسلام ونيبنا محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
انا اعيش حياتي حسب تعاليم القران فهم لا
يفهمون ذلك بالنسبه لهم فان المسلم
الليبرالي الا التقدمي ليس لديه علاقه
بالدين لانه في الغرب بشكل اساسي لا لم
يعد هناك اي شخص متدين في الحقيقه هم لا
يفهمون مجتمعاتنا وكل من يمارس الدين
بنسبه يعتبروا
متطرفا او رجعيا ولكن فماذا انا انا اعتبر
نفسي
مسلم
يعيش دينهم
ويطبق تعاليمه الدينيه وما هي مبادئ
بالنسبه لدوله مسلمه حكم القانون
الديمقراطيه والرفاه
حقوق الانسان
الحقوق الاساسيه للمراه
والمجتمعات المهمه او الضعيفه هذه هي
الفكره عن الاسلام ولكن للاسف
الغرب لديه فكره نمطيه عن المسلمين طيب
عندما سئلت في يونيو من عشرين واحد وعشرين
على قناه امريكيه عما اذا كنت ستسمح
للحكومه الامريكيه بتنفيذ مهام من باكستان
ضد جماعات ارهابيه او متطرفه العامله في
افغانستان رددت بكل حزم انذاك لا بالتاكيد
وهاي العباره كما نعرف انتشرت حتى اصبحت
شعار على قمصان اطفال باكستان الان هل
تعتقد انه هذه العباره فقط هي التي تقف
وراء كل مشاكلك
انا لا ابالي ولا يهمني
اذا ما قامت الدوله الاجنبيه او تعتقد بان
الاجنبيه ان اكون في السلطه
او يجب ان
اتملق لهم لكي يستلموا السلطه هذا لا
يهمني ما قلته واضح جدا باكستان
عانت من وفاته 80 الف شخص بعد نظام ذاتيه
حرب امريكا ضد الارهاب باكستاني سندها اي
علاقه في احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
والجدعيه السبب يدفعنا الانضمام الى
نزعتره اخر لدينا 100 مليون باكستاني
يعيشون في حاله ضعف
اما تحت خط الفقر اوفقه بقليل
المسؤوليه القصوى لاي دوله هي اتجاه شعبها
في خلال انضمام في الحرب الظل الارهاب
توفي 80 الف شخص او باكستاني ومئه مليار
دولار خسرناها في اقتصادنا فعندما قلت بكل
تاكيد لا ما قصته اننا لا نريد ان نكون
طرفا في نزاعا اخر نريد ان نبقى حياديين
واتمنى ان نركز على رفاهي شعبنا كل ما
ننضم الى اي نزاع فان الشعب يعاني طيب
عندك تقييم للموقف الامريكي تجاه ما حصل
في باكستان
حكم الحكم العسكري هو الذي يحكم
وهنالك تعذيب وانتهت كل القانون ويجد حكم
القانونيه ابدا لان المحكمه العليا
واحكامها يتم تجاهلها من قبل الحكومه وافق
كل شيء
الديمقراطيه فككت او تم تفكيكها في
باكستان ومع ذلك لا يوجد اي رد من حكومات
الغرب وكما قلتم مسبقا هم يتحدثون عن هذه
المسائل عندما تحدثنا عن كونغ هونج كونج
او انتهاكات حقوق الانسان في روسيا ولكن
هناك الصمت تام فيما يخص ما يحصل في
باكستان انا لا اريد المساعده من حكومات
الغرب لا اريد مساعدتهم كل ما اريدهم هو
ان يقفوا الى
جانب قيامهم التي
يدعونها والتي يعلمونها للعالم او يسمونها
بالقيام الغربيه اوردهم ان يلتزموا بها
ولا يهمك كانت روسيا او الصين او باكستان
او الهند يجب ان تطبق نفس القيامه مع
الجميع يجب ان يعيدوا الديمقراطيه وحقوق
الانسان وضد التعذيب وحكم القانون يجب ان
يؤيدوا كل تلك القيمه
عن عمران خان نتحدث عن حزبك واعتقالات
لعشرات الالاف اذا كانت المساله شخصيه
تتعلق بتصريحاتك فقط
قد نفهم الموضوع بشكل مختلف هل ترى بانه
هذا الموقف منك شخصيا
ما اقولهم انا انا لا اتحدث عن نفسي عندما
اقول انني اريد الحكومه الغربيه التي تدعي
بهذه القيم الغربيه كل ذلك لنفسي كل ما
اريدهم هو ان
ما يعانيه حزبي وكل عام لدينا وقياده
الغياب الكامل لحقوق الانسان والاساسيه
وهذه الحكومه الفاشله التي انتهكت كل
القوانين اريدهم ان ينتقدوا ما يحصل او
ذلك انا لا اريد المساعده في الختام
باكستان ستحل مشاكلها بنفسها نحن لا نريد
اي مساعده خارجيه ولكنني اريدهم ان
يتحدثوا ضد انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
في العالم رئيس وزراء احدى اكبر الدول
العالم او شهيد سياسي كما يصفك البعض في
هذه اللحظه اي صفه تعتقد انها مناسبه لك
لا يهمني كيف اتذكر الناس ولكنني سابذل كل
ماتي
اللي ما يصب في مصلحه بلادي وانا بدات
حركتي واسميها الجهاد قبل 27 عاما لان
العداله
هي عامل اساسي في ديننا واهم شيء يتوقعهم
ان الله
جل جلاله هو ان نحقق العداله على الارض
وهو واجبنا المقدس والعداله توفر والحريه
للبشر ولهذا السبب فهي امر مقدس لان كل من
يقاتل من اجل حريته هو شهيد في الاسلام
بالنسبه لي هو كفاح انا سافعل كل ما بوسعي
واذا ما قدر الله لي النجاح فهذا امر عظيم
وان لا فانا بدلت كل ما لدي هكذا ارى
الامر يعني قد افهم انك تقول تفضل الثلاث
القاب وليس واحده على اخرى قلت مره امام
طلابك ان سر نجاحك هو عدم تقبل الهزيمه
ابدا الان ومع وضعك الحالي هل يمكننا
القول ان السبب وراء ازمه باكستان يتعلق
بشخصيتك فقط وبافكارك فقط متى سيقبل قائد
فريق النمور الكريكت السابق للواقع ام انه
ما زال لم يقل كلمته الاخيره
انا اقول ذلك
بشكل مباشر لا شيء سيمنعنا من الفوز ان
شاء الله لماذا لان الحزب السياسي عندما
تكون لديه اكبر قاعده انتخابيه في البلاد
فلا يمكن هزيمته بامكانه كل شيء
كل
الاعتقالات ولكن كم شخص يستطيعون اعتقاله
عشره الاف عشرين الف
باكستان تعدادها سكاني 200 مليون شخص لن
يشكل ما يقومون به يفارق
اذا كان الحزب هو صاحب اكبر الشعبيه في
البلاد فسوف نستبدلها على الاشخاص وبلا
الشخص يفوزوا حزبنا وسنقول لك الان اذا ما
حصلت انتخابات سنفوز وهذا هو عامل
انتخابات
فكل ما تقولينهم
هواء الحرب حتى النهايه انا دائما احارب
حتى اخر قطره
لان كل ذلك هو لمصلحه بلادي ما لم يكن
هناك حكمه قانوني في باكستان وحريه عامه
اي الديمقراطيه والحريه فلن يكون لدينا
مستقبل ولذلك فلا شك بانني لن استسلم ابدا
خاصه مع علمي انه اذا ما حصلت انتخابات ان
شاء الله سنفوز رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
السابقه السيد عمران خان شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المقابله الف شكر
الى هنا مشاهدينا الكرام انتهت هذه الحلقه
من البعد الاخر يمكنكم دائما متابعتنا على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك
ويوتيوب كما يمكنكم متابعتنا على بودكاست
وايضا على شاهد تحيه لكم والى اللقاء